welcome we begin the day with the faces
of Elon Musk the new owner of Twitter
the man who declares himself a free
speech absolutist went on a suspension
spree last night shutting down the
accounts of several reporters from The
New York Times The Washington Post CNN
Voice of America and other media Outlets
it happened without any warning and no
reason was given what we do know is that
Twitter recently banned an account that
tracked the real-time movements of Elon
musk's private jet musk claim that this
was doxy that's when private information
such as addresses phone numbers and
emails are shared online usually to
harass someone Twitter has since changed
its rules it now prohibits doxy the
suspended accounts from yesterday they
do not belong to reporters who have
engaged in docs and yet this is what
musk tweeted today
same doxing rules apply to journalists
as to everyone else
and he then went into more detailed
tweeting
they posted my exact real-time location
basically assassination coordinates in
obvious direct violation of Twitter
terms of service
we're shutting down journalists it does
not sit well on this side of the
Atlantic the European Union has
threatened Elon Musk with sanctions
European commission vice president Vera
girova tweeting this news about
arbitrary suspension of journalists on
Twitter is worrying the eu's Digital
Services act requires respective media
freedom and fundamental rights this is
reinforced under our media Freedom Act
Elon Musk should be aware of that there
are red lie red lines and sanctions soon
one of the journalists who suddenly
discovered that his Twitter account had
been suspended joins me now Steve Herman
he's the chief National correspondent
with voice of America Steve joins me now
from Whitewater Virginia which is just
south of Washington D.C Steve it's good
to have you with us do you have any idea
why your account was suspended
well I don't know for sure because
Twitter never notified me of any reason
something just popped up on my account
saying that it was suspended and then
later there was a another message
popping up saying I was permanently
suspended it obviously had to do with
the tweets of that I had been putting
out about the other journalists who had
been suspended for tweeting about uh an
account that follows Elon musk's jet
that itself had been suspended so uh
this was uh growing larger and larger
and um it's obvious uh that uh I was one
of those who fell uh victim to what
appears to be a a pretty arbitrary and
uh inaccurate description of why we were
um banned yeah because musk has been has
been claiming that that journalists have
been suspended their accounts have been
suspended because they've been
committing doxing but I mean just to set
the record straight you and the the
journalists whose accounts were
suspended last night you were not
publishing any real-time information
about anyone's whereabouts correct
absolutely not uh including Elon Musk
which is what this is uh really about uh
uh apparently and to uh say that these
journalists were engaged in doxing which
would be giving out as you said
Somebody's location in real time uh
their home address their uh private
phone number for the intent of causing
harm to them uh to accuse the the
journalists of this including myself is
uh false ridiculous and I probably could
think of a few other words that we uh
can't say on the air you know it seems
that in the last few weeks Twitter has
really it has become all about Elon Musk
and I dare say that this is not what
most people were expecting when he took
over the company or or am I sugar coding
our memories of the recent past I mean
how do you see it
yes uh well I have been uh tweeting a
lot about Twitter because if you're on
Twitter you're interested in what's
happening with Twitter I'm not a
full-time tech journalist I don't cover
the uh uh the Twitter beat the Tesla
beat the Elon Musk private jet bead to
any of those uh sort of things uh but uh
it has gotten an increasing amount of
attention uh of journalists such as
myself who are very active on Twitter so
we have been tweeting and retweeting
others uh about uh what we have seen as
um uh greater uh instability on Twitter
both on the uh the legal administrative
and technical side
talk to me about
um reaction on your side of the Atlantic
I mean has there been any reaction
coming from members of Congress or from
the White House
a number of members of Congress uh have
uh put out statements uh today uh about
uh their concern uh regarding this
um and I expect there will be as the
hours go on uh more reaction uh to this
and and less uh these accounts including
mine are unconditionally uh reinstated
uh fairly quickly and Steve what do you
make of the Swift and the very direct
warning that came from the European
Union you know addressed directly to
Elon Musk
well as you're well aware there are
different levels of Engagement uh
regarding regulations uh uh concerning
social media and the internet uh on uh
the different chores of the Atlantic and
uh I'm not surprised uh to see the sort
of uh quick and uh forceful response uh
uh from the European Union uh especially
um I think they tend to be much more
proactive and and react a little uh
quicker to these things and although
things here in the United States and
Congress are politically uh very divided
and this is a time of year where not
much gets done uh there probably will be
more uh Congressional scrutiny uh of the
social media platforms uh engaging in uh
and these sort of activities uh in in
the future
and what happens next for you I assume
your account it hasn't been reinstated
so far are you plan are you counting on
it being reinstated at some point
I would sure hope so uh I would only do
it if it's unconditional I will not to
delete or take down uh any of the tweets
that I tweeted out if it is meant to
some sort of acknowledgment that I uh
did something wrong uh in any way I have
made um alternative uh plans so to speak
I did set up as an insurance policy a
couple of months ago I think it was uh
accounts on other social media platforms
uh last night when this happened I had 3
100 followers on Mastodon and that's
well over twenty thousand uh last time I
checked uh this afternoon on my time uh
I had 111 112 000 no followers on
Twitter yeah um so uh Macedon I don't
see as a replacement for Twitter but it
is some sort of alternative
Steve Hermann with voice of America
Steve we appreciate you taking the time
and sharing your story with us and we'll
be following to see what happens to
those accounts thank you
thank you